Okay, unser heutiges Thema ist
Umellenturing und sein sehr berühmter Um-
Artikel über Computermaschinen und
Intelligenz, der bereits
in der Zeitschrift Mind erschien,
und
dies ist ein wirklich entscheidender
Artikel, und bevor wir diesen Artikel diskutieren,
möchte ich etwas darüber sagen
Tourings Leben ähm im Hintergrund
seines ähm Artikels in seiner Philosophie
, wie Sie vielleicht wissen, war er ein britischer
Logiker, Mathematiker, Kryptoanalytiker
und Informatiker. Er ist einer der
Gründerväter dieser
Wissenschaften und gilt als einer der
einflussreichsten Theoretiker der frühen
Computerentwicklung  und
Informatik,
und er ist auch berühmt und besonders
berühmt für die konzeptionelle Entwicklung
der sogenannten Turing-Maschine. Wir werden
dieses Konzept heute diskutieren. Die Turing-
Maschine,
und er war auch eine sehr wichtige Figur
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs
Nachrichten, die mit der deutschen
Enigma-Roto-Siphon-Maschine verschlüsselt wurden,
und ich werde sho  w Sie,
wie diese Maschine aussah, das ist das
Symbol der Maschine und hier ist ein
Bild der Maschine,
Sie sehen es
und
Arno wird uns jetzt etwas über
den technischen Hintergrund dieser
Maschine erzählen
ein überblick über
die reichhaltige
forschung zum ehrenamt,
denn was ich im falle des ehrenamts unglaublich interessant finde, ist,
dass er in
sehr unterschiedlichen bereichen gearbeitet hat
und in gewisser weise sehr früh mit
spezifischen zukunftsweisenden ideen, die sehr oft
zu
fruchten
wurden  Vision viel später,
also
zum Beispiel, und dies ist eine besonders
interessante Geschichte, da die
Tiering-Maschine
aus einem sehr theoretischen
Kontext herausgewachsen ist. Es ist sehr interessant, dass diese
ähm ja diese theoretische Konzeption
einer abstrakten Maschine mit einem unendlichen
Gedächtnis
ähm,
dass dies gewachsen ist  aus einer Diskussion
, die in den
Diskussionen um die
Grundlagen der Mathematik wurzelte,
so war um 1900 klar, dass die
Grundlagen der Mathematik u  Sie sind weniger
sicher als gehofft,
und Leute wie David Hilbert versuchen,
die Grundlagen der Mathematik zu sichern,
indem sie
die
Regeln und
Verfahren mathematischer
Beweise mathematischer Demonstrationen
theoretisieren, und in diesem Zusammenhang war es sehr interessant, dass Leute wie David Hilbert und  andere versuchte eine
gruppe um david
hilbert zu
diskutieren, ob es so etwas wie ein
verfahren gibt
, das entscheiden könnte, ob eine bestimmte aussage eines bestimmten theorems
wahr ist oder nicht,
also versuchen sie
herauszufinden, ob es ein allgemeines
verfahren gibt, um darüber zu entscheiden  Wahrheit
mathematischer Aussagen
und
die Frage war
in gewisser Weise,
was wäre ein effektives
Verfahren, um über solche Fragen zu entscheiden,
also war die Frage, was ein Verfahren ist, was
ein effektives Verfahren ist,
in gewisser Weise eine offene Frage
und zu diesem Zweck in einem  Art und Weise, wie Alanturing
[Musik]
ein theoretisches Modell vorgeschlagen hat, sagen wir,
oder
ja, eine theoretische Maschine, eine abstrakte
Maschine, die
definiert, war  Was für ein effektives
Verfahren ist,
also ist es die Turing-Maschine und was die
Turing-Maschine berechnen kann, definiert,
was das Verfahren zum Demonstrieren in
Mathematik
wäre, ähm,
und der interessante Punkt ist sicherlich
, dass Sie alle wissen, dass ein solches
Verfahren einige beweisen könnte
etwas, wenn jede Aussage oder
was für jede Aussage beweisen könnte,
ob es wahr ist oder nicht, dass ein solches
Verfahren nicht existiert, wenn wir einen
axiomatischen Rahmen haben, der stark genug ist
, um eine Zahlentheorie aufzustellen, also ist
dies mit dem Namen Google verbunden
Sicher,
aber diese sehr theoretischen sehr abstrakten
Fragen,
die nur
für Leute interessant sind
, die von den Fragen der
Grundlagen der Mathematik besessen sind, haben
in gewisser Weise diese Idee einer Maschine ausgelöst,
die
durch
viel mehr Entwicklung und durch
Einbeziehen von viel mehr Ideen und Einbeziehen
eine riesige geschichte ähm
mit vielen menschen
diese
abstrakte maschine war gewissermaßen ein ursprung
ein äh ein ausgangspunkt für das was
computer nennen wir heute digital elektronisch
und
und was ich
nur anmerken möchte, ist eine historische
information
und dies ist bereits verknüpft mit dem
text von heute,
dass
der wortlaut computermaschine
zur heilung dieser frühen texte der
1930er
sehr stark
mit dem verknüpft war  Menschlicher Computer
Der menschliche Computer taucht auch in
dem Text auf, den wir heute besprochen haben,
und der menschliche Computer ist so etwas wie
ja, Leute,
sehr oft wurden Frauen
hauptsächlich dafür bezahlt,
komplizierte Berechnungen in einem Büro
durchzuführen, das waren menschliche Computer, die
an
sehr, sehr vielen Orten in arbeiteten  die naturwissenschaften
arbeiten in banken arbeiten in ähm
in vielen firmen
wo es notwendig war schwere rechnungen zu machen
aber das war eine aufgabe für
menschenarbeit menschenarbeit
und deshalb
taucht dieser human computer auf
und der digital computer ist
heute gewissermaßen der standard für unser äh
wenn man von computern spricht, aber zu turins zeiten in
den 30er und noch in den 50er jahren kann
unter computer auch
ein mensch verstanden werden  computer
das ist eine art remote site aber das
und das führt direkt zum text von
heute aber ich möchte nur zwei oder
drei
weitere hinweise hinzufügen weil
ähm
die arbeit und die forschung von alan turing
alan turing viel offener war während einer
war nicht  kerl, der gewissermaßen auf einem gebiet gearbeitet
und es immer weiter entwickelt hat er
hat auf verschiedenen gebieten gearbeitet, also haben
wir beim heilen nicht nur
die jubelmaschine den mathematischen zusammenhang
und die entwicklung der computer
in den 50er jahren
wir auch  Fragen wie
zum Beispiel
biologische oder Computerbiologie haben,
er hat etwas darüber geschrieben, zum Beispiel in Bezug
auf die Muster in der
Tierhaut oder die Strukturierung von
Tierteilen, auf welche Weise wir Computermodelle haben können,
um
die Genese dieser Art von Mustern
und biologisch zu verstehen  strukturen dies ist auch ein
weiteres forschungsfeld von jiren
und was ich besonders interessant finde
ist,
dass er sehr
oft gewissermaßen einen ansatz skizziert
und am sa  Zeitweise hat er einige alternative Ansätze im Sinn,
so hat er zum Beispiel
mit der Turing-Maschine das
, was wir heute unter dem Begriff Computer verstehen, theoretisch definiert, eine
symbolisch rechenregelbasierte
Maschine, aber
gleichzeitig etwas später auch konzipiert
etwas, was wir die ersten Anfänge nennen könnten,
waren nicht wirklich die ersten, aber
frühen Anfänge dessen, was
wir heute künstliche neuronale Netze nennen würden
, also prägte er in gewisser Weise
viele Grundideen,
die viel später fruchtbar wurden
und sogar in einem Text, den
er
sehr oft skizzierte  und skizzierte
verschiedene Herangehensweisen,
also möchte ich mich zum Beispiel nur daran erinnern,
und dann werde ich beenden, ich möchte
mich nur daran
erinnern, dass Sie sich
an die letzte Seite in unserem Text erinnern,
die ich
sehr typisch dafür finde,
dass er sagt, okay,
wir könnten verschiedene Herangehensweisen wählen
Eine solche Maschine zu bauen
,
die gewissermaßen das sogenannte
Imitationsspiel gewinnen könnte, darüber werden wir
heute diskutieren und das eine wäre  Sagen
wir gut, wir konstruieren eine Maschine mit einem
abstrakten intelligenten Verhalten, zum
Beispiel beim Schachspielen,
aber gleichzeitig könnten wir versuchen,
die kompliziertesten und leistungsstärksten
Sensoren
zu kaufen, um einer anderen Maschine Englisch beizubringen
, Konversation zu führen,
völlig andere Ansätze,
um die Maschine zu konstruieren
und  was sagt turing,
wir sollten beides versuchen
und
in gewisser Weise skizziert er damit, er macht auf
verschiedene Ansätze aufmerksam, um so etwas
wie eine
intelligente Maschine zu konstruieren,
und
für ihn ist es nicht entscheidend zu sagen, dass dies
wahr ist oder dass es nur ein
Ansatz ist  Das kann jetzt hilfreich sein,
möglicherweise müssen wir beide testen,
und mit dieser Art von Ansatz skizziert er in
gewisser Weise zwei Paradigmen der
Erforschung künstlicher Intelligenz,
möglicherweise das war es für heute, denn wir haben einen
Text, den wir bearbeiten und diskutieren müssen
ich möchte mich nicht zu
lange aufhalten vielen dank arnold für diese
einführung ich werde
kurz die wichtigsten fragen der heutigen
ses vorstellen  Natürlich haben
wir sie Ihnen im Voraus geschickt, aber
ich lese sie noch einmal. Wie stellt sich Turin
also Maschinen und Intelligenz vor? Wenn Sie
also von einer intelligenten Maschine
sprechen, müssen Sie zuerst definieren, was die Maschine
ist, und dann, was Intelligenz ist,
dann hängt dies mit der zusammen  erste
frage was ist das ziel dieses sehr
berühmten nachahmungsspiels arno erwähnte es
schon
damals, was kann das nachahmungsspiel
in bezug auf ai erklären und was
versteht durian ai nicht als
simulation oder als realität, also ist das
auch das konzept nicht klar  der
artifiziellen art der künstlichen intelligenz
ist nicht klar,
ob es sich um eine simulation
oder
eine verwirklichung von intelligenz handelt, also denke ich, dass
dies zumindest meiner
meinung nach eine der wichtigsten
fragen ist, dann ist eine andere frage, was
an der idee einer
lernenden maschine entsprechend paradox ist  Turing,
wie bewertet Turing dann die
philosophische Bedeutung von
Vermutungen? Ich denke, das ist eine sehr
aktuelle
Frage, also auch eine philosophische
Frage in Bezug auf die
Wissenschaftsphilosophie, also wie man mit
Vermutungen
oder Vorhersagen
umgeht und so weiter. Denken Sie nur daran, wie eine Singularität nahe ist, dann drehte sich eine andere Frage in seinen Vermutungen richtig und schließlich, welcher der von Turin diskutierten
Einwände der wichtigste ist  Eins, ich denke, das
ist auch eine sehr entscheidende
Frage, also werde ich
unsere Aufzeichnung jetzt stoppen und wir werden
dann mit
der Diskussion fortfahren und wir werden auch
einige der wichtigsten
Zitate dieses
Artikels präsentieren